your job was to  predict when a potentially catastrophic  event might happen in in space on a  space shuttle is that right i use  mathematics  and science specifically statistical  probability  to calculate  the probability of a catastrophic  explosion within flight and that job  required  the ability for you to look at every  single duct weld joint  material structure  and figure out how the hot pressures and  gases and temperatures  were going to affect how this particular  particular engine moved  and  how it would move in a way that was  designed versus a way in which would  rupture and break apart with a fire  [Music]  you're my pearl